so this will be pretty short and raw
because i'm i'm at my home office
here while the rest of the team offloads
and ingests the
dozens of hours of change my mind
footage because of all the multiple
camera angles i know some of you have
seen the
the teaser with the angry protester and
the police officers because uh
we got scooped on our own change my mind
by uh better news outlets but um
that'll be on wednesday you'll have a
little more context and we have a few
more coming actually down the pike
um i want to talk about a couple things
though also that the camera might be
doing this because my shoulder gets so i
don't know how people do they have like
a stand
because it'll be doing this gradually um
i wanted to talk about the the really
sad
you know it's just a sad reality now
that you have a lot of conservatives uh
out there blaming
video games for these shootings i want
to talk about the shootings in general
shoulder switch
um along with the aftermath that we
commonly see and why you often don't see
me speak out so early but before
before that you know let me let me
lighten this up a little bit i broke my
nose yet i think i broke my nose
yesterday
this is a story um that it's really just
a testament to my
my stupidity sometimes i was at the
hotel gym and they had these
what i thought were medicine balls right
so this was before the change in my mind
and they were the exact they looked just
like the text not like old leather
medicine balls but they're kind of
texturized rubberized
sort of balls that you would use for
maybe like wall throws or ball slams you
know against the wall
uh against the floor and uh i was in a
rush
so i uh thought well okay you know i'll
grab this ball i'm very familiar with it
a 14-pound ball and i'll just do some uh
some ball slam throw it against the
floor turns out it was
uh basically a 14 pound super ball
so i whip it down my head's two feet
from the ground and
all that right up in my face and i must
have just been on all fours in this
hotel gym myself
i would love to see the security footage
if we can i'll call the hotel if someone
has access to the security footage if
you were the guard on duty please send
it to me
i was spitting out blood because i cut
my lip but i was bleeding from my nose
so i don't know if you can see actually
my eyes are a little bit um i just
touched it that was stupid to me
uh but what happened you know what
happened that there was a bone right
here in my it looked like there was this
big bump in here
and i couldn't really breathe until i
just went in and this will be a meme i
went in and i
poked it and it went crack and then i
was better and now when i read it just
feels like i have the world's biggest
booger in my nose so
i don't know i think i broke my nose um
before we get to the whole video game
thing which is just so disappointing to
me i can't even put into words
you know i will say this i'm gonna go
against the grain here i know it's
really
really popular right now the cool kids
say oh thought
thoughts and prayers yes send your
thoughts and prayers sarcastically
you know insinuating that thoughts and
prayers do nothing um
i don't think i've been someone who's
really offered thoughts and prayers a
whole lot i usually just offer prayers
because
i'm a praying man i may not be popular
you may not like that that's
these are the abcs of me but you know
what you know what that is
it and it's it's like a merry christmas
it doesn't really mean anything
someone's not doing anything for you
they're just trying to symbolically show
you
good will and in this case when people
say you know my prayers are with you
what they're doing is they're saying you
know what this is a tragedy
the likes of which we can't possibly
comprehend if our our family
uh members haven't been the victims
themselves
i'm praying for you man uh it's it's
it's completely out of my control and
usually it's married with if there's
anything i can do if it's someone if
it's a neighbor but someone you actually
know you can't really do that on twitter
so i have no problem with it and i will
tell you i am praying for the families
of those involved you may think it's
useless flying spaghetti monster well
fine i guess i'm not one of the cool
kids but i will say this right after you
know before the bodies are cold of
course you have
mom's demand action everyone just
politicizing this pushing the gun
control narrative
and talk about fake news talk talk about
fake news i mean i was amazed i watched
cnn
for six hours in the morning uh after
the dayton ohio shooting and
we certainly knew a lot more about the
dayton ohio shooter you know self-about
extremist socialist elizabeth warren
supporter hated republicans
uh whereas the other guy from el paso uh
yeah would seem like a racist white
supremacist sure seems like he may have
liked donald trump but he also quoted
the lorax
he also was a neo-environmentalist who
thought we were over harvesting
resources so
i'm just talking about if looking at a
consistency of a world view as to the
reasoning for
for killing people senselessly uh in
some of the worst strategies
tragedies we've seen in recent memory um
the dayton shooters one that's pretty
clear but cnn for our saying we don't
know enough yet we don't know anything
about the shooter no
we did and you know what else we know
we know that video games don't cause
shooting sorry i keep switching my
shoulders here because my
i don't have a stand i'm sorry but my my
arms get sore i'm not
i'm a mere man like you i'm really
disappointed to see this
to see republicans trot this out because
you know what this is how we lose
this is how conservatives lose and
rightfully so and i've seen some people
out there say you know what i really
liked trump until now we see these red
flag laws and uh
you know when you have the republicans
and donald trump echoing uh
violent video games hey
and i can't refute that i have no i have
no retort to that you know what
all i can say is yeah yep
i hear you it's a really crappy thing to
say and a crappy thing to do
to go out here and blame video game who
are you tipper gore
what are we bill clinton are we going
back to columbine now we know there's no
correlation between the two no
on a personal note when i have children
guess what they're not going to be
playing
what's what's the rating for video games
the 17 and over they're not going to be
saying
seeing r rated films just like they're
not going to be playing video games that
are made for adults
i think that's a good rule of thumb okay
and i don't think it's good for kids to
be desensitized to
any kind of violence or gratuitous
sexual content at any age
that that's a personal issue that being
said to blame these issues
right now to blame the issues or the the
what they paint is a gun epidemic
and it's not it's not an epidemic this
is also something that bothers me it
pulls away from the issue that we really
should be talking about you know the
united states doesn't lead the world in
violent crime not even close
doesn't leave the industrialized world
in violent crime not even close doesn't
lead the world
in gun crime not even close doesn't lead
the industrialized world
in mass shootings either none of those
things are true but guess what
it's really hard for people like me and
you to go out and make those arguments
when
unfortunately we're put on the defensive
because people for some reason think
that we're proxies or representatives of
the republican party
i know i'm not i am a conservative i'm
open about it i don't cop out and just
say
libertarian or independent because i
don't like labels no i'm fine with the
label conservative that being said i'm
not a proxy for donald trump by any
means but it removes our attention and
our ability to cut through
the [ __ ] when we have to address
that no
no of course i don't agree with
president on the video games
no of course i no that's not the issue i
don't even want to have to deal with and
you know what
republicans conservatives if you are
even remotely consistent in your
ideology
you wouldn't put people in that kind of
a position
okay i you know i see some people and
this is one thing i
the trump die hard to support him no
matter what he does and they say oh
you can't possibly understand the
pressure he's like i get it they want to
blame donald trump for everything you
know a good example it was uh
what's her name ah forget not brook
baldwin someone at cnn there yesterday
um polly something i can't remember she
yesterday
watching cnn she said that donald trump
reversed a policy from barack obama
that uh bard mentally deranged people
from purchasing assault weapons
no no that's not what happened right
what actually happened was
this was a law that i think the aclu
even came out against where
older people senior citizens who were
declared
unfit mentally unfit to manage their
pensions
they'd been stripped of their second
amendment rights and that
was reversed let's see that's fake news
that's the kind of stuff that we should
be talking about
but when people who we hope we hope
represent our views to some degree let's
be honest i don't think donald trump
necessarily knows all of his views i
agree with a lot of them i think he's in
a pretty good job
i think he's done a crappy job the last
couple of days
i don't even know what i was thinking i
was i was talking about something this
is what happens sometimes when i
just i'm talking to a phone and i'm this
is so awkward when people talk to phones
i don't understand how they do it
but i do want to know what what you guys
think out there do you
you blame this on video games you think
that's a problem do you think
you you blame it on on background checks
on the background checks that we already
have
do you blame it on the nra i think there
is a component to this
and we talked about this that changed my
mind yesterday
people don't like to hear this they say
well how would you fix this problem you
know what
you can't if people are being honest
right now
you can't fix the problem you can't fix
the problem of evil
you can't and it doesn't mean you're
being insensitive it doesn't mean that
you're not acknowledging what a horrible
tragedy this is
it it doesn't mean that you are not
willing to call out evil for what it is
but you can't fix evil
okay and certainly you don't you don't
jerk react because people are saying you
need to do something now and they push
push some legislation forward that would
rob people their basic right to
self-preservation and wouldn't do a damn
thing to curb the violence listen we
have over 300 million guns in america
okay the vast majority of americans are
gun
of gun owning americans are law-abiding
citizens guns firearms are used
far more defensively than they are
offensively united states even if you go
to the uh
i don't know i don't know depending
which which statistics you use from the
fbi or
cdc 500 000 to 3 million defensive uses
of firearms each year
you have countries with very stringent
gun control that haven't necessarily
curbed gun violence
we don't lead the world in gun violence
we don't lead the world of mass
shootings and we are
very far from leading the world in
violent crime
and you know what else you don't get rid
of video games
and you don't make video games the
boogeyman of the day i don't play video
i don't play video game i've been
thinking about getting back into it
maybe i should i don't know
the last video game that i really played
was i played medal of honor
quite a bit um you know i played halo i
played star wars battlefront i haven't
played video games though in a while and
i thought you know with most of my down
time i tend to do nothing
i didn't just binge watch shows or like
go to the gym or something like that and
it gets pretty boring and it's just
because i'm usually so tired that i
don't want to play card games i don't
want to do anything that's mentally
taxing
um maybe i should get back into them i
don't know enough about video games
today
but i do know that you're just like
you're not going to strip citizens of
firearms you're not going to prevent
criminals from obtaining firearms
you're not going to stop people from
enjoying and engaging in one of the most
profitable industries in the united
states and by the way
that's that's not really a bad thing
when you compare it to
drugs when you compare it to alcohol
when you compare it to
nearly any other industry of vice i
understand that some people have
problems with video games i understand
that some video games are being marketed
to kids when they shouldn't be played by
kids i understand that some people
apparently can get addicted to video
games maybe there's some truth to that
but it's one of the biggest industries
we have it's a
wildly popular exponentially growing
sector of the
i don't know if people call the
entertainment industry if it's just
media or if it's tech i don't
necessarily know how you classify video
games
but not only is it wrong to do sorry i'm
going off on rabbit trails here again i
didn't really sleep much we were flying
last night for the
to change my mind um not only is it
wrong to do not only is it incorrect
to do and i mean that in both sense both
senses it's not only
wrong and that it's incorrect but it's
also morally
wrong to do to blame video games
it also is strategically a really stupid
mistake
i think you lose a lot of people a lot
of new people who've come into the fold
because they're pro free speech because
they're many of them pro second
amendment um because they don't like the
authoritarian left you know they didn't
leave the left
left left uh the left left them the
whole walk away movement when you see a
lot of these people now who are who are
newer who are into the folder figuring
out
what they're about certainly if you look
at more young conservatives or
libertarians or
right leaners guess what a lot of them
play video games
and right away you lose a whole swath of
the country and so i really hope that
president donald trump and i really hope
that all the other republicans
there in the in the swamp right and it
really was a swamp gosh
my i had to change shirts i was a swamp
when they were there in dc yesterday i
hope that everybody in the swamp
um gets the right consultants
for some reason they're playing by the
old late 90s playbook where they want to
blame
you know they want to play natural born
killers and in woody harrelson and video
games and i
maybe they think it'll get the left off
they're off their tail
from claiming that they're paid that
they're bought and paid for by the nra
which of course they aren't if you look
the money that goes around from big
unions or planned parenthood it's not
even comparable the nra is just this
boogeyman that they're trying to
scapegoat
so they try to scapegoat the nra and
firearm owners i don't want to see
people who should be supporting
liberty and you should be supporting you
know factual cohesive arguments
blaming video games and making them out
to be the same boogeyman that the left
tries to do
with guns themselves how about we stop
blaming inanimate objects
and we acknowledge that we don't
necessarily have all the answers we'll
do what we can within reason as long as
it doesn't infringe on people's rights
but we can't always necessarily fix evil
it's unpopular
it's the truth